what's up will how can i help i would
love to hear your perspective and get
your advice
on how i can help my younger brother out
he's
having a lot of trouble uh just really
getting his life together
and it's not it doesn't really listen to
what other people are saying would love
to hear your perspective
give me a little more information if he
doesn't listen to you this is a pretty
short call
because i'll just tell you yeah he won't
listen to you man um so
like what is your role what is your
influence in his life and what is he
struggling with
sure so in in the past he's had a very
wild
lifestyle you know like all the drugs
and
um you know lots of different people
sleeping around stuff like that
yep um and she sounds a lot like jen's
child's
a lot like james back in the booth yeah
and he's
um he says he's moved on from that but
he's never really moved
forward if that makes sense so he's
having trouble holding on to a job
and um he uh so like he'll have a
stressful day at work and say well that
was a stressful day so i need to take
the next week off and you know there's
the
you can't hold on to a job and so he uh
is just really having trouble moving
forward we have a
a good relationship and he's he's says
like he really looks up to me and
and he uh you know my opinion means a
lot to him and
and so i try to help him out and give
him coaching and
he knows all of the right things to say
um so i always uh for the last several
years
like i'll i'll talk to him about
something and say okay here's a plan
here's what we can do to get you in a
better place and
and he'll say all the right things that
i feel encouraged and and then he just
doesn't
doesn't do it you know how old is this
um and uh he's 25.
um and so all of this kind of came to a
head um
a few well maybe a couple weeks ago now
he texted me at like midnight and was
just like i just want to die man i just
i just can't do this anymore and
um you know and i was trying to talk to
him and um
and calm them down and i said well you
know are
are you are you wanting to hear what you
know what i have to say this time
because not
i don't want to hear it and so he just
he was like i just want to get stuff off
my chest so i think he's
you know he it's like he wants to listen
but he knows
he's not going to do it either you know
like he'll he knows the right things to
say but he's just not going to do it
are you in a place where you can meet
with him in person
yes okay so
i'm going to break your heart and then
you're going to
i'm going to give you some tools okay
um truth is you can't help your brother
other than connecting with him and
letting him know that you love him
he doesn't need another plan he doesn't
need another
routine it's not because he doesn't have
the right planner
it's not because the right background
music isn't playing during his workout
it's none of those things what the the
behavior you're talk you're telling me
about tells me there's a history of
demons there
some of which you probably know from
your childhood together some of which
you probably have no idea about
and dude he needs a brother that's going
to love him and it's going to hold him
accountable and it's going to love him
and it's going to love him
and sometimes that love means you know
where i'm at
sometimes that love means if you and so
here so that's the hard part right
you can't help him he's not missing a
plan okay
he's gonna have to make some decisions
on his own in concert with community
that he says i'm gonna i'm gonna make a
run of this and i'm gonna
i'm gonna be whole i think he'll come
around because he's got a big brother
that loves him like crazy
what he needs more than your judgment
right now is your connection
and here's what that's going to look
like okay
i don't want you to bring up his past
with him anymore
if he wants to talk about some some
things decisions he made in the past
that he doesn't agree with
great i don't want that to be a part of
your conversation with him anymore
i want you to love him right now and
love him for where he's going
not for the things that he's done okay
he carries that shame around enough he
doesn't need it the second thing is i
want you to get with him
in person and i want you to tell him i
don't know how often you say this you
may say this all the time a lot of
brothers don't but i want you to look
them in the eye and say i need you to
hear me say these words
i love you and i'm glad i'm your brother
i will be here for you always
i'm here and if you
ever threaten to hurt yourself i'm
calling in
everybody i'm calling 9-1-1 i'm calling
mom and dad i'm calling
any i don't know grade school teachers
i'm calling everybody in the fire
department the neighbor i'm calling in
everybody
because that's over my ability to help
you and it scares me and i'm not going
to lose my brother
and i want you to let him know when he's
ready
you're going to continue to text him
you're going to continue to
leave voicemail messages on his machine
you're going to write him letters
you're going to continue to let him know
he's tethered in
but until he comes to you and knocks on
your door and says hey i'm ready for
some a plan i'm ready for some
accountability help me out here
he's just going to continue to leave
interactions with you
filled with shame because he's not you
he's going to leave interactions with
you exhausted because he can't do the
things big brother will's doing
okay and i know this is hard i know it
is but at the end of the day
you have to draw boundaries around
yourself he's going to have to make some
hard hard decisions
and man there are a few things more
powerful than a brother who loves
another brother
right but nobody who i love
gets to threaten suicide without me
calling in everybody i know
nobody around me who um i love
is gonna not know that i don't love them
right
i don't know if i just said that the
right way i'm gonna let them know that i
love them that's what i'm saying will
okay and i'm also going to let them know
i'm not going to judge you anymore
i'm not going to try to force things on
you
i'm just going to be here and i'm going
to be thinking about you every single
stinking day
i'm going to pray for you i'm gonna
always answer the phone when you call
but that's the best i can do and will
i'm telling you right now he needs
connection he needs people who are not
gonna
say well you know if he needs love love
and connection and that's that's that
right so thanks for that call man i do
want to know how that conversation goes
will
i want to know how it goes and it's best
had in person it's best had planned
have it let him know that he's loved
maybe this
i'm gonna i'm gonna add an addendum
write him a letter and give it to him
after that
um at that breakfast at that lunch you
have with him
write him a letter and hand it to him so
we can take it home and read it and read
it and reread it and i don't want it to
mention
anything about the past i don't want to
mention anything about i can't believe
the decisions you're making none of that
i want to be short and to the point i
love you i'm
so glad i'm your brother i'm so glad i'm
your brother
and i love you love you love you and
when you
ever need anything i'm here love will
that's it that's it everybody needs a
brother like will
put the judgment down start connecting
man